وهو بالضبط ما ردت به موسكو فهديه اعياد
الميلاد من روسيا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
كما يقول نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسيه متر مادفا انها الفرقاطه الادمرلك
جورج كووف التي اعلن بوتن عن اطلاقها قبل
ايام لتبحر بالقرب من شواطئ دول حلف شمال
الاطلسي هذه الفرقه تصفها روسيا بانها
سفينه حربيه متعدده الاغراض ومزوده باسلحه
صاروخيه موجهه ومصممه للقيام بمهمات في
البحار والمحيطات
الفرقاطه قادره على حمل صواريخ مختلفه من
طراز كاليبر وكينغال وتسيركون وكروز لم
تعلن روسيا ما اذا كانت ستبحر في اطار
مجموعه من القطاع البحريه لكنها اعلنت ان
الفرقا بها انظمه دفاع جويه قادره على
حمايتها من التهديدات تبحر الفرقاطه اذا
بعد تدشينها في رحله طويله تمر عبر المحيط
الاط ثم تدخل البحر الابيض المتوسط وبعد
ذلك تنتقل الى المحيط الهندي يوم تدشينها
اطلقت صاروخا تجريبيا من طراز سيركون
الفورت الصوتيه من مياه بارنت سي لتصيب
هدفا في البحر المتوسط نتحدث عن مسافه
تقدر باربعه الاف كم الصاروخ سيقان هذا
قادر على التحليق بسرعه بسرعه تزيد عن 11
كلم في الساعه بمعنى انه يستطيع القيام
بدوره كامله حول الارض في اقل من اربع
ساعات سرعته الخارقه تجعله قادرا على
الهرب من اي نظام دفاع جوي في العالم
وتقول موسكو انه لا نظير له في اي مكان
وهو قادر على حمل رؤوس حربيه مختلفه
بالتاكيد منها الرؤوس النوويه كما يمكن
اطلاقه من البر والبحر